http://www.youtube.com/timedtext_cs_panel?tab=2&c=UCCwg160JGGBZMRFhDaeJkzw
I'm oceanic
Welcome to bay wash our hands of the elite of the elite
with the heart soul of this very beach
Come on. Feed make my pecs a little bigger and don't cover up my front bumper you guys used a big dick
We're staring into the abyss here. It's up to
restore the Baywatch Brand
Air One direction you here for the qualifier. I'm matt brody. I don't have to dry out. I've got some gold Medal
Hey Road map Road again. We still don't
Raining begins at Oh-six-Hundred it is nothing you would see me people
What is that you think we do here prevent people from getting sunburned occasionally stopping from drowning?
I can't save you if you're being a dick
This is a guy you think it's a good pr. Opportunity for us look I get it the big desk. Wash. I'm fat
Fuck that shit touch of evil stock
Drug much dead body on our beach, and it all started once she took over some people are up to no good
We're gonna have to do what they watch this bad the truth is one of you will probably die. Yeah, that's pretty what no
The only one to think this is clearly a job for the police
Thank you blue. Eyed Demon. You got one job. Make sure to swim happy white people don't drown
Why does he look like returning in Slo-mo the reason? I believe in God we go undercover
Yeah, I'm undercover yeah, little few undercover
Jason bourne and got shit on me
Why are we in the morgue you got to get some hard evidence? You must come and put it here now now. We hi weird
I'm I wanted all three murders are empty. [why'd] you [pick] [that] Troy?
Coming true. It's just a little dead man's back necrotic liquid back, and we stopped you too, baby
That's it about
you